you're welcome to this video playing Tim
am here and uh 2510 pool so yeah let's
go for scien i really wonder shouldn't I
do model oops what happened here I don't
see myself in the best lesson 25
shouldn't I be in the best list down
maybe I'm not they're not not enough
games ok anyway let's see we got the
time online that i recently played quite
a bit let's see what is doing the most
no most topical this Bishop e3 this
English attack set up yeah here's an
interesting moment white can play Bishop
year 31 King age one these are the two
big moves it's at the moment where you
can play h5 random I think it is there
is some a line like that when 94 now is
an idea but sure what is he actually
yeah anyway it's an interesting move ok
ta never know in those instances how to
recapture maybe politics is not so bad f
for I have five I guess playing a bit
too quickly i'm still in blitz not
usually should think for a moment down
if you have the 25 minutes you should at
least spend a moment on the opening
that's somewhat longer time control I
mean the likelihood that some mistakes
are going to be punished it's just I am
so have to be especially alert GI
threatening a 45 that's not something
that I can't allow i think i have to go
if I the disposition yeah allowing him
if I've just is just bad if he takes it
a plane IG form yeah I'm sitting there
with no development whatsoever that's
not good on the other hand if he takes
only 5 94 I might get a great Knight to
e5 f5 is the more yeah obvious move
let's say I had a very similar position
in the European club card last year and
be bow which it takes so okay well Nyjah
for something that is that he it's
useless to spend time
yeah okay there is this opportunity
after 9065 for him to take on h5 that
really might be an issue an important
point is that he is threatening the move
the movie 6 so maybe what about but
should be sick said an idea what is that
is that rubbish there should be six my
DS to operate with that is a group the
aid and things like that way I think I
can do this Bishop c5 is also an
interesting move that can that might
come in handy later it's an important
thing that after he if he goes h3 h3 now
I don't have to move that night I can go
Bishop c5 as he cannot capture on g4 due
to mate with the rook on the edge file
let's check the other ratings of that
guy yes five minute isn't great but is
decent and 15 playing the 45 45 leak I
think I haven't played in reform
yeah what is he playing now interesting
it might be somehow good for him but not
easy and 95 I think I can check with the
pawn cd5 ed five and maybe rope the aid
okay so he decided to decided to move
that Bishop to d3 huh what is the idea
maybe we never three something like that
that the idea maybe okay an interesting
question is do I take only five or not
now I can't mean I can't delay this this
caption and play something like Bishop
c5 I just i'm not sure if it is a
particularly good ndm to do that because
after if i take only five now the the
future move Bishop to d6 might be might
come in handy on the other hand the
night on g4 is also on gun interesting
an interesting active piece Bishop c5
has one point that might be Bishop d4
and taking on a high with the bishop
that's of course even more desirable
than taking with in mind if I would get
in Bishop c5 d4 takes only five and
maybe this is good right that could be
interesting let's do that if I get to
take only five with the bishop there is
a huge likelihood that the bishops are
getting traded and if the bishops are
trade at the dark squared Bishop then a
night only five would be just a rock
yeah it cannot be disturbed than by
bishops making it a fantastic piece it's
it would if it would be a good piece if
it just takes only five immediately but
it's it in a pin and this e5 square that
it's occupied by the
it is the case where many pieces want to
be on that square by Bishop would be
would like to be only five the night
would like to be only five and actually
getting in something like bishop d for
Bishop takes five and trading the dark
squared bishop would be a fantastic
achievement strategically speaking so
I'm intending to play Bishop g4 of
course they snide F to check but that's
not something that was very high on my
list of priorities so we should be for
that was the the whole point what I'm
wondering is if I go Bishop deform if he
actually can go 95 in this position is
that possibility bishop d 4 95 c takes
it takes I mean I don't really have a
great great square to go for my for my
bishop so is it an idea to Castle long
maybe just start with long castles here
with a queen on f3 we absolutely can
never go I mean you can't play a tree
but you will not be able to take the
night ever maybe just castling long is
there something particularly of pudding
I don't see it so i'm getting i'm doing
this mostly that i can take twice on d5
if he gets 95 in yeah that's really some
problem of whites position here that the
knight on c3 is just looking at
protected square c 6 and be 582 isn't
very attractive be for us occupied by a
pawn whites position actually would be
far more attractive if there wasn't
opponent before
that he can that he would have been able
to play 94 lat same so Bishop g4 that's
really the move that that is that's the
obvious move let's aim so they're not
really i don't really see a huge problem
or any problem with it so let's do it go
for Bishop takes d5 as I said that is
the strategically desirable way to play
kick on d5 with the bishop and possibly
get bishops traded now we both played
relatively quickly here 25 10 is some
time control where you can take some
time yeah I don't really know what he
what he is supposed to do now I
personally don't like White's position
at all but it's probably not that bad if
you play it correctly now even though I
cannot tell you really what you should
do if I get in I mean let's just say he
plays whatever I don't know a three or
something which doesn't make much sense
but then Bishop b5 Bishop takes d5
community xe5 is brilliant on 9085
that's both brilliant for black I have
the the better pawn structure better
bishop in relation to that to my pawns
it's very very nice better Bishop is
probably a bit wrong but the bishop on
d3 is not helping much but I also have
my fair share of pawns on light squares
however yes that pawn on e4 which is
really not helping with with having a
bishop on d3 yeah he has to look at that
scenario Bishop takes five maybe he has
to play something like g3 but then I
have aged form and my player on the King
side is accelerating on tremendously
yeah I only know what he's doing now
that Bishop d3 Queen f3 a DM yeah
doesn't really strike some as
particularly as particularly great
very often if you are in this in a
slightly or in a better worse position
and ideas to try to improve the worst
place peace sometimes if you actually
don't know what your worst place pieces
because there are a couple that usually
you are really in trouble yeah I think
can you do something maybe what about
that knight on c3 is there some way to
activate that maybe you can try nah but
also not good thinking maybe nitey to
Bishop b5 and then some trying something
to get the Knight to f4 later disturbing
me a little bit but I don't really see
how this is this should happen yeah it
just doesn't look good I don't know what
is what is move is what is some
intention is now
hmm not easy not easy difficult
difficult to move and there are some
some problems with with very concrete
lines for example let's just say a place
Queenie to attending Bishop c4 trade of
that Bishop I take only five with the
bishop and if he takes on me 5i tea with
the Queen threatening made on h2 when
that already gets downhill very quickly
yeah g3 h4 black bag is probably winning
there so it's not not at all easy
yeah to be honest I don't really think
that taking only five is that that great
an idea it is only really a good option
if you can justify the structural
concession with some very concrete plane
sacrifices like 95 or something really
really drastic but it doesn't really it
didn't really materialize maybe there
simply was no really active possibility
ya know is taking a long long time I
understand it's not easy to find
something good
maybe he always thought that I would
take only five with in mind and he can
build his play around that pinning
situation he didn't really recognize
that idea with this suspicion mc5 d for
IDM
yeah uncomfortable
maybe he will play some kind of non move
like a three at the end simply of
failing to find anything anything
substantial
no I don't really have a great advice
fam seeking taking forever here but it's
not disconnected wow it's got the best
connection ever saw as you see Wow 21
milliseconds latency must basically live
next door to that server cool that's a
great great connection ok anyway
connection can be as good as you can
imagine but so it doesn't help with the
position running out of ideas what to
chat about Jim really don't seem when
you don't see a good good good idea then
interesting okay Bishop takes five is
the most obvious move yeah let's do that
and I want to second-guess here that
much it cannot be bad really at least I
would be very surprised so it takes them
yeah I think Queen changsha is the way
to do it operating with that made threat
on edge to always nice to threaten
checkmate in one so okay that means that
after rookie one he has to take with
night or bishop okay check on f4 then
rook to at the end it's also not bad how
interesting
I can also take and plane i to III but
not sure about this but taking here des
to take with with the minor piece looks
attractive for Ellis at Tiki and put and
get his route to f4 which is not the
most attractive position
okay but is this really everything that
I have or is that something entirely
different meaning I can also just take a
form
I take you one probably the bishop will
take take a four-week f4 and 95 this is
a very one-sided position maybe this is
the simplest I don't think I have much
something that is much better okay let's
go for that
that better probably not let's take and
put the night IAM
so I have that fantastic night only five
but is that really leading to something
concrete what is his move I think most
likely something like 933 our king g one
question is can I do I have to invest a
move on g6 to cover the pawn or can I go
look dat media day one point is that
after a possible Bishop takes h5 I might
have g5 tempo rook moves and then g for
the bishop is somewhat strap them on h5
so not quietly Everneath the g6 move at
all playing look 28 quicken has them
benefit of maybe allowing in very early
rook to detune
roop t8 bishop 85 g5 look somewhere then
g4 threatens the night and threatens
look h8 winning that piece I don't
really see an antidote to that now the
question is maybe I have to apply g6
later anyway it's definitely possible
but as long as I'm not forced i'm not
sure that i should play it and now
Bishop takes h5 I think it's definitely
not working g5 tempo group and then G
form that I don't think so the trappers
that traps the bishop
self self trap are 93 that looks som far
more sensible so this might be a moment
where i am i will now can actually avoid
I don't think so it's probably not
possible to avoid them off it also takes
a five away and so it's not not bad whoa
that is surprising putting more on light
square or is he just is it a said idea
to just go to just go something to see
form maybe
yeah i was thinking worked for may be
intending g5 and c3 rocky to looks
terrible
the night see form I can take with the
bishop and after Bishop takes you for I
ever no no no I will take sorry if you
put something on c4 I will take twice
and then after let's say Nancy for
Bishop c4 Bishop c4 not c4 busy for play
at five that's important pinning on the
fourth-ranked okay this move that's
surprising I thought after g5 and Luke
takes before I'm just winning a pawn for
no particular compensation isn't that
the case maybe that's wrong that's the
wrong idea group d qu es rope f2 and not
sure that that gains me that again to be
much
one issue is let's say rook f6 group
takes you for the night only three hands
and he cannot move it as e 2 is also
hanging therefore it's a bit of an
unlucky spot maybe him he has to play
like book F to know okay so I'm grabbing
the pawn so here I am he's in forking
distance with nijah forward doesn't look
like I get an easy easy for again he has
night f5 as a possible
hmm what's what's easiest th for I guess
right not f5 I always have kingly 7 ok
let's go H for getting rid of that
somewhat weakish Paul of course that
Luke only for it has a nice-looking
central position but it's also a bit
vulnerable at the moment however was not
not apparent that he has something good
so some things are downright bad they
are like no Bishop d3 level can take you
three and win a piece
poof that's mysterious or does that move
on about taking away more squares from
our look I guess ok I can take them and
handle it from here is their threat I
don't see it at the moment
Bishop d3 has snow move at all can I
just activate my king here King d7 maybe
yeah I don't really see why not maybe I
should play a five and a five a form
would highlight a drawback of that c3
move weakening be three now that that
would have been interesting actually
even instead of King 27 I really don't
see how he rest is my rook we should be
free I just take it
yeah if I reform it's a good idea
probably gather look is it doing
something brilliant I don't know I can
just do this I think
try to use that rock really on the
fourth-ranked with the a4 idea yeah what
has very little town to play with this
rook rook H a drupe g8 that takes two
moves
okay that just takes one move um so is
it is it an issue
yeah I don't know a form giving that
back I don't know if that's a great idea
but playing g4 also feels a bit wrong
hmm
the move f6 rook h7 that looks wrong and
really wrong to allow this kind of
activity
yeah I definitely can go g4 but it's not
it's not exactly a dream scenario
and f6 is also bad if i go a fry
probably will go rook takes g51 taking
on a phone yeah okay I'm keeping that
let's keep the pawn it's not just a pawn
it also takes away squares like a three
in particular not ideal but probably
still the right move one issue is that
if I go a four and he takes it I cannot
easily recapture with the rukon a4 as
the night only five is hanging so I have
to consider move like King 2d6 maybe
which runs into checking distance of
that night that's not yeah that's not
something that you like to allow but
very likely it's not a problem at all
the end well here's to play a move first
em
yeah note how good a piece by bishop
only seven only success so it was placed
there moved 12 and is very nicely
positioned down being yeah anchoring
anchoring them them being anchored 26
okay while trying to find words for
things my opponent has just given me the
a to pawn so should I take it or not
it's difficult to believe that I
shouldn't take it night d3 check kingi
to maybe I even have a better move but I
don't see it let's see one check king d
290x a2 and King be three king be three
as a bit and a five Hanks that's an
important thing
okay now that's not so clear really
isn't and Bishop c2s now on on his
agenda
okay Bishop see towards the next move
very likely my roof doesn't have squares
that sets that's really really the case
one thing I was the thought of as 93
check King King to e2 groupie five if
you then takes I'm have this minor piece
and game with the porn it's not easy to
win definitely not but probably still
the best option
93 checking it to rookie five here other
CF Bishop takes two for them and
nonsense the king is on YouTube ah
stupid stuff rupee five I think that
should be good actually so check let's
do it so night see one check king d 2
nite takes a two you can take on 85 and
this okay i take c 3 then maybe King t3
no that's not really really a problem so
maybe I should just take take stuff they
are not see one and nine takes a tune he
also has king d 3 at the end of that
line night see one kinky 290x a two and
then king cakes d three yeah maybe I can
play Knight takes c3 then as weird as it
looks might it might just work
rookie 5 is the other move if he trades
it heads of course a very nice endgame
and if he moves the look i still have 91
so let's let's do that it's probably
probably put a good choice it's possible
that maybe night see one was yeah like
tactic tactically winning something that
was just taking advantage of this
somewhat awkward situation I wonder by
the way if he moves the rock the move
Knight to c5 is also not to be sniffed
at because night x 94 is a pretty big
threat looking at that pawn on g3 okay
that doesn't matter because he traded
and looks yes yeah night 22 F for that
was something that I had thought about
but couldn't really believe to be that
grade I can even go Bishop to g5 in this
position yeah that's a good idea I think
neither for Bishop every check that
looks very very nice driving his King
back yeah yeah that's not bad at all
check so is there a better move than the
immediate trait I don't think so so
let's take it and go from here a night
night on again on e4 would be really
nice night 24 is there are some way to
get it there quickly f3 g5g form is a
possible possible route it's not really
threatening to regroup his night so that
my that that Ponce will be hanging
quickly the night on King the six King
297 King III Knight f6
hmm doesn't seem so convincing
mm okay not you not totally sure what
the best way is to do that technically
let's start with this one yeah kingi
talking d2 it's very likely
hmm
9 to e 6 something like that also be
quite nice but
maybe this maybe this heading for a for
allowing king e 5 the right moment yeah
that might be an idea 95 and then kingi
5 494 later so nice c5 the first move in
that sequence ready for King e5 next
and I have 936 sometimes and he really
never can trade even though my pawns are
not that active at the moment I would
always be able to use the extra porn
with f5 King e5f for check and so on he
will run out of moves sometimes so 96 is
some possibility so here I wanted to go
King I five though being active and
allowing a possible night to e4 I didn't
want to go into e6 but to inform
pressure rising c3 and looking at at g3
okay so if i go nitey for now they're
only really meaningful move there's a
check on d3 but after King f5 I will
take on g3 next okay have some time
don't be shouldn't be rushed them my
district checking a five I don't I don't
really see it and nighty to just losses
due to norm let's say losses to normal
moves 90 to the easiest probably being
f5 yep f5 intending night XD 3 for the
f4 fork his sort of moves now night XD 3
it's not there's no defense against that
can remove the night ok King d3 maybe
yeah maybe this one
I can just go be five or something IBM
be five is a bit that's not him and he's
got 94 which is unnecessarily
complicated relatively speaking ok so I
can check on to 30
quite resigned okay let's do a recap of
that game yeah a nice Sicilian game in
the tomorrow yeah he went with this King
each one aged 5 and I'm not completely
sure what the main continuation is now I
think it is this I think this is
something that is actually known like
some something like that is the is the
theoretical continuation but okay you
took and when def for ya now he's
threatening to play five so if i play am
lame movement he will get a very nice
position I mean besides maybe bishop age
5 or something but it's just it's just
good for white as pollution I have to go
in five there is no doubt them okay he
took it and I'm yeah I don't like it so
much unless he has something very
concrete which is possible maybe but it
some other than that this is the normal
move just gaining space down in the
European club cup I had almost the same
position but the bishop was on d three
already okay so he took it I went here
very normal movie should be six yeah he
was reassessing this so if i take here
there are some awkward ideas yeah that
would lose we should be six is better
anyway so when to Bishop d3 yeah that's
a that's really a lame move inside
somewhat somewhat to make him the
computer wants to play this interesting
yeah taking control over that important
square and asking blackboard what is my
next move do this for example I can even
consider this invasion I interesting
very interesting position now that
that's probably what you should do that
this is really a meek really meet move
Bishop fc5 that's good this is probably
a threat even though I would have be
sometimes reluctant to play and yeah
because that's such a nice prospect of
putting the night only five later it's
probably just good to start to take the
exchange of he would allow it okay he
played here and now alone cancelled yeah
this move might run into 95 we had the
half the engine agree sir that that
really looks dangerous a lot yeah I mean
this is more than dangerous so along
castles is very logical and here's the
move where he took know where he led
that he played relatively quickly yeah
the engine already gives black a huge
advantage so I was right I really didn't
see anything great this idea Bishop
before is very strong this move Bishop
g4 we should be too it's relatively best
according to the engine there should be
five Bishop takes d5 Queen Queen f4 yeah
interesting now do I take here or do I
take on f4 I mean it probably needs to
close close close to the same positions
yeah here whoop dat
that was interesting I wasn't really
sure if it if it Nets me that much but
rock t two is probably really strong hmm
now i am that's probably better but that
does not really give away much here yeah
if he takes it I go g5 yeah Angie for
I'd I think I'm trapping that but the
computer does not agree I add this of
course yeah this is not even that clear
okay yeah that's true that's true so but
that that is supposed to be good okay ya
understand that that's a that's a nice
option just with the rook on the second
rank okay maybe better even then the
edge 6 p-3 I went down and now we played
just guy and I just took this ok I am
that the engine gives this move which I
did not see takes root each one sorry
ticks ticks oops who takes root chicks
chicks now let's not let's know but not
an advantage night at five that's a good
way to try to defend they don't have
such a great move there i can go here
and continue it it was much better night
at five after this i took it eh freund
again black has a substantial advantage
here check Teague's and 85 Norman King
d7 yeah if I've immediately was may be
more precise look here and again a five
went here and okay the engine oops oh I
made a blunder here night f1 with 92
oops barack ah oops so i should do this
I mean I saw that but I was thinking
that this is not as convincing as chief
or but I did not he went here I didn't
see that move their retreat moves with
the night are tricky that's true but
still I should have seen that idea I was
aware that my rook is short on squares
but wow what an embarrassing movie my
rook doesn't have any square the engine
wants to do this check and assesses this
is equal check my rook is somewhat
active maybe I can draw but wow that
would have been very awkward you did
that check and now I'm really better
here right yeah this yeah okay Bishop
before it's also a good move to store my
shouting but the night end games with
extra pawns of very often winning this
here q5 him I think it's just really a
witness it wasn't the toughest defense
ever that he put up here but it's really
a win this end game so he had this this
is China's chance this opportunity when
I played the G form that was this big
big opportunity in their game to play
night everyone and after you missed that
that chance um yeah I'm basically
winning winning in that end
okay that was interesting Sicilian
battle hope you enjoyed that game thanks
for watching